[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de Paf
avec une actualité très chargée donc on
va vous présenter tout de suite
verdict Jérôme bonjour bonjour à tous
vous êtes Polito économiste et vous êtes
maître de conférence à l'Université de
Paris Saclay
Raphaël m'attaque vidéo bonjour bonjour
Patrice bonjour à tous bonjour alors
vous êtes bêtes de conférence à
l'Université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
en droit public on va parler avec vous
évidemment de ce qui va se passer
peut-être au Conseil constitutionnel et
puis vous êtes aussi marathonien puisque
vous avez vous avez effectué le Marathon
de Paris de boutons roux et vous allez
nous raconter cette expérience quand
même assez exceptionnelle avec plaisir
tout à l'heure et puis Florence percadio
de Versailles et on va commencer avec
vous parce que l'actualité c'est la
visite à la prison du Bois-d'Arcy du
ministre de la Justice
Dupont-Moretti du président du Medef
route Béziers avec
industriel
des Yvelines et l'idée c'est de fournir
du travail au détenu et permettre
évidemment de ressortir de prison oui
c'est une c'est aujourd'hui
ils sont ce matin voilà
cette d'abord c'était une
expérimentation et maintenant c'est
devenu encadré juridiquement pour pas
qu'il y ait de dérive puisque les
rémunérations des détenus
sont inférieurs au SMIC c'est 45% du
SMIC et il y a des entreprises à un
moment donné qui ont quand même
largement abusé en payant encore moins
en sous-payant et puis ensuite en
instaurant quasiment un lien de
subordination avec les détenus donc ça a
été bien encadré et effectivement
le Medef Yvelines avait organisé il y a
plusieurs années une visite de la maison
d'arrêt de Bois-d'Arcy pour avec le
directeur pour promouvoir cette
initiative de travail en détention et à
cette occasion là il y avait cette
industrielle qui faisait partie des
entrepreneurs qui faisaient cette visite
et il a depuis mis en place ce système
de travail en détention avec des détenus
donc il fournit le matériel il y a une
pièce dédiée il fournit le matériel
il donne une formation assez
détenu et il y a une un contrat qui lit
cette industriel à la maison d'arrêt de
Bois d'Arcy qui est un contrat cadre sur
les relations entre l'entreprise et la
maison d'arrêt et sur ce que
l'entreprise attend en termes de travail
de la part des détenus donc il y a pas
de c'est lui il paye la maison d'arrêt
de Bois-d'Arcy et la maison d'arrêt de
Bois-d'Arcy va rémunérer les détenus qui
travaillent en cotisant
pour les détenus qui travaillent comme
un salarié comme un salarié lambda et
cette industriel donc a développé ce
travail en détention et il embauche des
tenues quand ils sortent pas tous mais
certains détenus qui sont les meilleurs
et ils les embauche ensuite dans son
entreprise dans le cadre de la
réinsertion ce qui est vraiment une une
initiative assez exceptionnelle à
l'intérieur de la prison et la
réinsertion par le fait de trouver un
travail exactement
et donc le travail peut être tout type
de travail en prison là en l'espèce si
on est dans le monde industriel donc
c'est de la mécanique mais ça peut être
ça peut être à peu absolument n'importe
quoi je sais que dans certains avions
notamment je crois que c'est Air France
où il y a des plateaux-repas qui sont
fait par
des détenus il y a beaucoup de ce genre
de contrat avec les avec les prisons ou
c'est assez exception
[Musique]
marginal mais justement cette opération
de ce matin où il y a Eric
Dupond-Moretti geoffroyau de Baisieux
qui est donc le président du Medef
il y a la préfecture
le président du Medef qui est là c'est
que c'est important pour les entreprises
c'est une opportunité pour les
entreprises j'allais dire sur le plan
financier avec un niveau de travail qui
est plutôt bon de d'autant plus qu'il
les forme donc c'est un investissement
de l'entreprise en termes de formation
en termes d'équipement de de cet atelier
et il y a un retour bien évidemment en
termes de d'abord un c'est une facture
qui paye à la maison d'arrêt de
Bois-d'Arcy donc il paye en facturation
le prix
c'est totalement interdit et donc le
prix qu'il verse c'est
45% du SMIC et une partie évidemment il
couvre les cotisations que la maison
d'art il faut que la pour la maison
d'arrêt ça y a pas de il y a pas de coup
voilà et au contraire il y a une
réinsertion ce qui est quand même tout
qui est quand même très bien dans ce
milieu là donc
en effet ce qu'on fait à la sortie ce
que vous voulez insertion surtout pour
les détenus qui sont là sur des alors
Bois-d'Arcy c'est une maison d'arrêt
donc normalement il y a pas de détenu
qui purge de peine sont des détenus qui
sont qui sont en attente de jugement en
attente de jugement il y en a certains
qui sont condamnés qui passent par la
maison d'arrêt avant de partir en centre
de détention mais c'est quand même c'est
comme très bien pour ceux qui sont dans
l'attente d'un jugement qui ont leur
jugement et ensuite qui vont sortir ou
pas mais
centrales ça peut exister partout
on va organiser donc je dois organiser
avec cette industrielle
au niveau du MEDA Yvelines on va
organiser à nouveau une visite de la
maison d'arrêt de Bois-d'Arcy avec des
entreprises
pour qu'elle sache que alors elles vont
savoir que ça existe si elles écoutent
les informations mais
elle va justement les sensibiliser à
l'intérêt de le faire et que voilà les
détenus sont pas forcément des barrières
absolument les gagnants gagnants pour la
maison d'arrêt pour l'entreprise et pour
les détenus c'est important
de d'assurer la réinsertion en fait des
détenus et ce qui est intéressant vous
l'avez souligné ce qui est intéressant
c'est de voir que au départ c'est une
expérimentation au niveau gouvernemental
qui permettait justement de de mettre en
place des initiatives assez voilà c'est
originales pour permettre justement ce
travail de réinsertion cette
expérimentation a été évaluée comme
étant positive et donc finalement le
gouvernement la pérennisé et voilà c'est
encadré je trouve voilà c'est quand même
c'est essentiel
le taux de personnes qui répondent
favorablement parmi les détenus je ne
sais pas parce que c'est sur la base du
volontariat j'imagine
après il peut vouloir se former aussi
peut-être qu'on peut y avoir des
informations
de la formation
professionnelles
pas du tout une formation manuelle c'est
un peu compliqué quoi après alors sur le
plan alors j'ai entendu ce matin
justement à la radio une entre un détenu
qui faisait du codage et des logiciels
donc ils peuvent pas bien évidemment ils
sont pas sur internet il y a rien c'est
ensuite la maison d'arrêt qui envoie ça
un prestataire pour que ce soit ensuite
mis sur internet mais l'idée de tenue
font le codage de logiciel
et donc ils ont une formation au codage
et ça c'est sûr que quand il Sorte de
détention il y a une demande incroyable
de d'embauche de codeur
[Musique]
puisque ça se déroule aujourd'hui à la
prison de Bois-d'Arcy et on y reviendra
peut-être dans d'autres éditions
Raphaël on va on va parler de vous on va
parler des confessions de marotoniens
[Musique]
c'est joli les confessions de
marathoniens absolument oui j'ai
l'impression d'être
vous avez donc couru le Marathon de
Paris dimanche c'était votre premier
marathon non c'était mon 5e marathon et
le quatrième à Paris le quatrième à
Paris et alors vous êtes comment là
j'ai mal aux jambes mais c'est normal
mais sinon vous êtes parti sans trop
d'entraînement pour des raisons pour
diverses raisons j'ai été j'ai une
préparation on va dire catastrophique
mais donc finalement j'ai quand je suis
parti je n'étais pas sûr de terminer et
j'étais ravi de terminer et peu importe
le temps finalement mais l'important
c'était vraiment de d'avoir pu parcourir
ces 42 km durant dans Paris dans une
ambiance qui est
extraordinaire alors on a eu peur au
début puisque la météo était très très
changeante et très pessimiste mais au
final on a eu un temps clément parfait
pour courir finalement
plein soleil pas de chaleur pas trop de
vent pas de pluie donc c'est finalement
et non par contre vraiment c'est une
manifestation
grandiose je me permets de remercier à
la fois l'organisation mais aussi les
bénévoles parce que plusieurs minutes
bénévoles qui c'est vraiment des vols
absolument avant pendant et après et
puis toutes les forces de sécurité
l'organisation la sécurité civile voilà
mais sinon courir dans Paris sur les
champs traversaient tous les paris
différemment où est-ce qu'on a le temps
de regarder alors ce qui me concerne on
a le temps de découvrir de redécouvrir
parce que je cours dans Paris
actuellement on a le temps de découvrir
Paris durant le premier semi-marathon en
partant des champs jusqu'à Vincennes et
au retour un petit peu vers la Bastille
par contre à partir du moment où on a
franchi le semi-marathon regarde plus
ses pieds regarde plus la ligne la ligne
blanche on se fait la ligne voilà par
contre on entend et on écoute les les
encouragements c'est c'est classique en
fait
c'est un peu ce que disent les gens qui
participent vous avez au chemin de
Compostelle en disant on va pouvoir
penser réfléchir à soi et bises au bout
d'un moment on pense que ces pièces à
ses ampoules
c'est un peu ça aussi mais c'est vrai
que il y a les participants
parmi les participants c'est il y a de
de tous horizons il y a pas que des
enfin il y a des beaux sportifs tous
évidemment mais là où je suis assez
surpris c'est de voir tous les toutes
les morphologies toutes les morphologies
des grands des petits des personnes
fortes très fortes on a même qui court
enfin qui courent qui ne court pas
pardon mais qui qui marche et qui ont
des des cannes et mais qui sont quand
même inscrits et qui font et qui font le
marathon et qui arrivent
oui mais 7 8 heures et 2020 c'est
terminé
le plus âgé à 93 ans la plus âgée à 83
ans
personnel c'est une épreuve sur soi
aussi
je pense que quand on court le marathon
il y a plusieurs objectifs un soir faire
un chrono un temps passer du temps avec
des amis ou alors aussi pour pour se
dépasser soi-même
non moi j'ai
solitaire avec 50 millions de personnes
mais non voilà et puis voilà je préfère
courir tout seul mais en même temps ce
qui est amusant c'est que souvent ce
pendant plusieurs kilomètres on court
avec quelqu'un
on trouve des camarades de courses au
fur et à mesure donc
un très bon temps
voilà les champions les les européennes
ça peut un peu plus de deux heures
l'Éthiopien alors j'ai mal prononcé son
nom c'est
Ian il a mis deux heures 7 heures
pour un marathon oui ce qui est là mais
le baron de Paris à cette particularité
c'est qu'il est valonné
il y a beaucoup de tunnels on se rend
compte où il va donner accès beaucoup
plus que quand on marche normalement
quoi la première femme la cagnotte a
terminé en deux heures à 23 c'est moi
vu passer et c'est impressionnant c'est
à dire qu'il court plus vite que que
nous quand on sprint quoi en gros et
c'est absolument
alors eux ils ont pas il y a pas de
beaucoup de morphologie différentes
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est que
moi quand je suis parti on arrive on
part des champs on arrive à la Bastille
et donc on est quoi là cinq six
kilomètres même pas et on voit déjà les
premiers qui sont sur la fin du semis
pour partir vers le bois de Boulogne
donc en fait c'est
une demi-heure ils ont déjà quasiment
terminé
ça vous tente non Véronique j'adore
marcher mais 42 km je trouve que la
distance c'est
un vrai exploit
euh Viroflay Chaville Meudon c'est donc
ça c'est c'est pas mal moi je connais
bien aussi le Paris Versailles c'est une
belle course par contre c'est très jolie
course le seul problème enfin je vois
deux problèmes le premier c'est que ce
ne sera pas un parcours à record parce
que il est tellement vallonné que voilà
ça sera compliqué et j'ai peur mais ça
c'est voilà c'est par rapport à ma
pratique j'ai peur qu'il y ait
comment dire je pense que intramuros ça
aurait été un petit peu plus
magique voilà j'ai j'ai peur que sur une
partie sur la partie Ville d'Avray
Boulogne ce sont un petit peu plus
étendue un peu plus oui c'est joli
c'est joli mais voilà c'est c'est juste
ce cet élément là qui me c'est vrai que
il y a yes ce mode la même chose à New
York
il y a une ambiance à Paris évidemment
il en veut absolument particulièrement
en même temps c'est des Jeux Olympiques
donc
voilà mais non c'est un très beau
parcours c'est pour le marathony
Versailles
bon on parle un peu de la situation
politique
sociale et juridique c'est à faire des
des retraites alors la question c'est
comment s'en sortir quoi
[Musique]
il y a plusieurs
thèmes sur lesquels on pourrait réagir
elle est un politique on voit bien que
ils avaient de borne est en train de
recevoir les partis politiques et le
recevoir aussi les cas donc il a
dimension sociale et puis il y a une
dimension
juridique qui est très important puisque
le 14 avril je crois le conseiller
constitutionnel doit rendre
sa décision sur la loi enfin valider la
loi où on retirer quelques quelques
articles où on a validé quelques
articles pourquoi c'est important
Raphaël alors
et pourquoi on en parle cette on parle
souvent du Conseil constitutionnel mais
là on en parle comme un enjeu essentiel
de ce que vous fait rarement d'une loi
alors on en fait un enjeu essentiel à
plusieurs titres et il faut que j'essaye
de me
de bien numéroter tous les tous les
éléments la première chose c'est que
là ça va être le moment pour le pour
c'est pour l'instant la réforme phare du
second Cancun
qui a suscité un nombre de d'opposition
donc là ça va être le juge de paix d'une
certaine manière le Conseil va être
celui qui va valider ou non la loi ça
c'est un premier élément et qui
permettra peut-être à la suite du
quinquennat de se dérouler dans des
conditions plus ou moins oui
ça c'est sûr après ce qui est important
c'est ce sont les éléments les moyens
juridiques sur lesquels le Conseil
continuel a été saisi il y a cinq
recours qui ont été déposés au Conseil
constitiel 4 de l'opposition enfin des
oppositions que ce soit à l'Assemblée ou
au Sénat et une de la première ministre
la saisine des parlementaires elle a
vocation a fait échouer la réforme ça on
s'en doute la saisine de la première
ministre est intéressante parce que
alors c'est rare c'est rare que le c'est
rare que mais c'est pas mais c'est mais
ça existe c'est rare mais la volonté il
y a une double volonté soit c'est de
légitimer sa réforme
soit c'est d'éventuellement de trouver
un échappatoire et d'éventuellement
avoir une censure qui permettrait qui
permettrait au gouvernement voilà
et surtout de ne pas perdre la face donc
ça c'est bon ça c'est
ça ensuite il y a trois points
essentiels sur le plan juridique qui
peuvent être qui peuvent être
intéressants et ce sont les éléments des
saisines ce sont des éléments
procédureaux je vais pas rentrer dans le
fond de la réforme c'est pas d'ailleurs
je suis pas le spécialiste sur ce point
mais trois éléments procédureaux le
premier élément c'est de dire que la
réforme a été adoptée par un cap ce
qu'on appelle un véhicule législatif le
projet de projet de loi rectificatif sur
le financement de la sécurité sociale et
donc en fait ce qui est dit d'après les
parlementaires c'est que en utilisant
cette ce véhicule législatif le
gouvernement avait en amont anticipé les
problème et l'obstruction parlementaire
ce qui permettait au gouvernement de
solliciter des articles de la
Constitution notamment le fameux article
47 alinéa 1- pardon qui permettait de
raccourcir le temps des banques il y
aurait eu une détournement de pouvoir ça
c'est le premier élément deuxième
élément c'est la teinte au droit
d'amendement de l'article 44 de la
Constitution les parlementaires estiment
que le 49-3 le 47-1 là d'autres articles
de la Constitution la mobilisation
dérèglement antérieures de l'Assemblée
nationale et du Sénat bref pour bloquer
là encore ou raccourcir les débats on
portait atteinte haut et certaines
irrecevabilités aussi qui ont été
déclarés par le gouvernement sur près
d'un millier d'amendements
ce sont les parlementaires 252
parlementaires de mémoire qui ont saisi
le Conseil constitutionnel pour déposer
un une proposition de loi référendaire
visant à limiter l'âge de la retraite à
62 ans
donc le Conseil constitiel doit
actuellement et que tu dis la
recevabilité de cette
pignons
le Conseil doit vérifier que le projet
de loi la proposition de loi pardon
rentre bien dans le cadre de l'article
11 de la Constitution c'est-à-dire
une réforme d'ordre social économique
bon la priorité ça devrait y aller
ensuite il ne faut pas que le projet de
référendum porte atteinte pardon et pour
objet de d'abroger une loi adopte
promulguée depuis moins d'un an
et la troisième condition c'est que on
ne peut pas revenir par cette
proposition sur un sur un référendum
négatif depuis moins de deux ans
si le Conseil constitutionnel considère
que le projet est recevable et bien dans
ce cas-là il va le soumettre à
l'Assemblée qui permettra ensuite de
discuter du projet de loi et après de
recueillir ces fameux 4,8 millions de de
ah oui de pétition pour ensuite
soumettre au référendum donc c'est la
première
le Parlement n'est pas du tout obligé
même si il y a eu 252 personnes ça fait
pas une majorité donc le Parlement n'est
pas du tout obligé de de d'approuver le
texte non absolument et après alors par
contre si le président estime que il
estime de voir
donc on a quand même un certain nombre
d'étapes avant de voir le référendum
arriver le président a bien le dernier
mot
considérer ou pas
que le président
parce que évidemment il y a vous avez
d'ailleurs dit il y a une dimension
politique dans la raie que la décision
va prendre le conseiller constitutionnel
d'une façon générale enfin si on regarde
l'histoire de des décisions du
conseillerais est-ce que cette dimension
politique existe ou est-ce qu'il reste
plutôt sur des critères purement
juridiques et purement constitutionnel
alors
où est-ce qu'on peut répondre pas
répondre à cette question j'ai répondu
différemment le Conseil constitutionnel
dans ces décisions et dans ces dans ces
déclarations quel que soit le président
soit Laurent Fabius ou avant il se
cantonne toujours à l'élément juridique
il refuse même si dans sa jurisprudence
dans ses décisions il se refuse à juger
en opportunité politique d'accord mais
voilà je ne dis que ce que dit le
Conseil constitutionnel ensuite il y a
bien des
entre il faut bien dire entre les lignes
c'est que sur un grand nombre de textes
le Conseil fait quand même de la
politique et parfois ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que dans ces dans ces
décisions où il motive peu ben là il
fait de la politique
quand c'est très motivé c'est qu'on est
dans le dans
cette peu motivé on peut dire que
l'opportunité prime sur le sur le
juridique le politique passe par ce
qu'on peut dire s'il veut faire que du
juridique sur une Inter
juridique de textes exactement
avec un axe finalement politique
effectivement
[Musique]
comme vous le dites c'est quand même une
indication politique forte
position voilà
sur ce sujet
montre déjà une couleur politique et
peut laisser entendre qu'il y a en privé
et le président
entre le gouvernement et LR par exemple
où ils sont pas tous d'accord
sur le plan politique
a été donné une mission Elisabeth borde
qui était d'élargir la majorité
ça semble assez compliqué en tout cas ça
semble assez compliqué tant qu'on n'a
pas
défini un programme sur lequel
on pourrait élargir cette majorité le
plus simple ce serait peut-être
d'ailleurs de commencer par définir je
sais pas les cinq grandes réforme qui
vont faire voler avant la fin du
quinquennat ça me paraîtrait la bonne
méthode on n'est pas parti comme ça je
vous semble-t-il c'est un contrat de
gouvernement en fait c'est un peu ça des
contraintes
suggéré je crois que Rachida Dati on
avait évoqué maintenant façon ce plan
sur le plan d'un appel à l'aide de la
part du gouvernement qui a une majorité
relative à l'Assemblée forcément en
ayant une majorité relative c'est
compliqué de faire passer des lois ou en
tout cas des lois l'importance
fondamentale qui sera marqueur parce que
le problème ce qu'on dit c'est qu'en
effet ce qu'on va pouvoir continuer
pendant quatre ans avec en cherchant des
majorités d'idées sur telle et tel
projet en faisant des concessions ce qui
fait que les choses sont plus très
claires
sont souvent taxés d'immobilisme parce
que finalement peut-être aussi parce
qu'on a tout fait au premier mandat avec
le second c'est finalement une
accomplissement mais plus important ici
la difficulté il y a un paradoxe
intrinsèque qui consiste à considérer
que normalement le président se fait
fort d'avoir dans son programme des
réformes qui sont des vrais marqueurs on
veut le nécessaire trace donc ça va être
compliqué de donner une image
consensuelle à une réforme qui devrait
être celle du président ça je sais pas
si je me fais bien comprendre mais voilà
si c'est vraiment son idée même sur les
retraites on l'a bien vu tout le monde a
considéré que c'était une idée
préalablement émise par la droite
c'était pas la réforme de départ que que
voulait manuel Macron voulait faire il a
fait des concessions pour arriver à
bonormal enfin très difficilement mais
quand même à faire accepter les choses
donc une vraie réforme qui lui tient à
cœur qui sera avec un vrai marqueur ça
va être compliqué il y a des sujets où
c'est encore plus compliqué enfin les la
fin de vie notamment entre autres mais
bon voilà et puis entre autres ce que
j'aurais dire aussi c'est que il faut
voir ça des deux côtés qui va accepter
d'entrer dans dans le groupe il faut
faire une analyse quoi avantage il y a
une rumeur qui nargit que Gérard Larcher
pourrait devenir poli ministre
en tout cas le personnage après ça
dépend de la capacité
au nouveau Premier ministre d'amener
avec lui un certain nombre d'élus qui
voilà qui renforcerait la majorité
présidentielle pour le goût mais en même
temps il faut pas que le personnage soit
trop fort dans l'image qu'il donne parce
qu'il fera de l'ombre au président donc
il lui faut quand même quelqu'un c'est
peut-être le moment quand même je suis
désolé mais c'est vrai que l'un des
problèmes d'Emmanuel Macron c'est
d'avoir plutôt pris toujours des
collaborateurs comme premier ministre
même si c'est très brillant plutôt que
des gens qui ont une stature politique
peut-être que il se dit que c'est le
moment de passer à autre chose
rempli plusieurs cases en fait
l'expérience la connaissance du terrain
les réseaux le territoire c'est vrai que
il remplit beaucoup de cases après c'est
vrai que c'est la récent polémique sur
le sur sa retraite ou sur la recette des
parlementaires qui permettrait de
disqualifier et en venant c'est vrai que
le Sénat a été grandiose là dessus en
venant j'ai j'ai réfléchi à qui à qui et
j'ai pensé à un autre ancien un ancien
président du Sénat alors c'est peut-être
parce qu'il est arrivé j'en sais rien
mais Jean-Pierre Bel et je me disais que
Jean-Pierre Bel pouvait aussi faire
aider le président socialiste sous le
sous le mandat de de Hollande et je me
disais que c'était peut-être un
personnage qui pourrait faire aussi
consensus
dimanche qui est assez intéressant c'est
à dire la défaite de la dép et sortante
elle est fille face à une socialiste
qui ne veut pas d'alliance avec
Mélenchon aussi parce que on parle de on
parle de LR mais il peut y avoir aussi
un certain nombre de
socialisme enfin d'anciens de sociaux
démocrates
ben comme celle qui vient d'être Éluard
et qui permet peut-être justement
après il y a le troisième point c'est
évidemment le dialogue social il y a on
va bien voir ce qui va se passer jeudi
est-ce que la manifestation va être
mobilisé beaucoup de personnes ou pas
quels seront les relations là il y a de
nouvelles secrétaire général de la CGT
et puis il y a quand même la CFDT qui a
demandé une pause
alors la CGT demande le retrait total de
la mesure la CFDT demande une pause on
voit bien que là aussi il y a peut-être
des des appréciations différentes ou des
non Véronique la CGT reprend parce que
la parole de Martinez était plutôt
convergente et consensuelle convergente
avec celle de Laurent Berger il était
prêt à demander lui aussi une pause
enfin on le sentait plus c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il a été un peu
mis en difficulté maintenant on peut
être d'accord avec ces Sophie je crois
Binet qui veut c'est son premier son
premier jour donc forcément elle va elle
va chercher le crédit
il faut qu'elle rassemble faut qu'elle
donne dégage à tout le monde et qu'elle
n'aille pas trop loin mais on dit
beaucoup quand même que c'est pas une
bonne nouvelle pour le gouvernement que
d'avoir Sophie Binet en place le CGT
parce que elle a ce côté un peu
réformiste un peu un peu moderne que
n'avait pas Martinez donc là elle va
aussi vouloir
conserver sa crédibilité donner des
gages
à la CGT mais pour l'instant ce sont des
effets d'annonce si on imagine que le
Conseil constitutionnel valide la CFDT
normalement doit dire STOP parce que
berger avait dit qu'il accepterait la
décision et donc là on peut sentir
quelqu'un qui aura une
un retrait fin de la part de en tout cas
des plus génitaux
tout le monde a envie d'en sortir donc
ça fera un peu moins de monde dans les
rangs ça ferait un peu moins de
manifestations moins importante etc n'y
va plus maintenant voilà alors le
problème c'est la base la base peut
déborder mais la base a un autre souci
c'est il y a des caisses de grève bien
sûr mais c'est juste que quand on peut
accepter de faire grève et ça c'est le
nerf de la guerre c'est c'est en 2010
enfin avec la réforme Sarkozy verte des
retraites qui avaient été voté je crois
27 octobre le 28 il y avait une
manifestation qui avait qui avait
beaucoup mobilisé et puis après il y a
eu deux autres manifestations et peu à
peu il y avait une démonétisation on
peut penser que ça allait un pas la même
chose sauf que à l'époque il y avait une
majorité présidentielle sauf qu'à
l'époque
Sarkozy pouvait se représenter au
présidentiel enfin il y avait des
différences politiques sauf qu'à
l'époque il y avait aussi une alternance
crédible avec avec le Parti socialiste
et c'est vrai que les circonstances
politiques étaient très différentes de
cette d'aujourd'hui circonstances
sociales et économique sont différentes
aujourd'hui parce que il y a le problème
de la retraite mais il y a le problème
de l'inflation il y a le problème des
salaires il y a le point d'énergie
justement donc ça ça grège toute une
série de de revendications et de très
fort mécontentement de la part de la
part de la population mais si je peux
juste revenir 2 secondes sur sur
effectivement sur la retraite je pense
que ça a été moi je critique très
fortement la méthode parce que je pense
que si dès le départ il y avait eu
c'est-à-dire qu'ils vont ils l'ont fait
à l'envers j'ai l'impression c'est à
dire que si dès le départ il y avait eu
des discussions avec les syndicats sur
les conditions de travail sur la
pénibilité sur la problématique des
seniors sur genre comme on fait pour
garder les seniors dans les entreprises
mais je suis bien placé en tant que
avocate de voir que on garde pas souvent
les seniors en entreprise et c'est un
vrai problème donc s'il y avait eu toute
cette discussion avant pour régler tous
ces problèmes là puisque là c'est réglé
de façon assez malade avec l'index
senior qui va se faire retoquer parce
que c'est un cavalier ça c'est sûr donc
il va y avoir un problème dans cette
dans cette dans la loi s'il y avait eu
déjà tout le débat qui veulent avoir
maintenant qui veulent pardon oui
absolument
et c'est passé ensuite voilà et c'est
ensuite c'est passé par la commission
mixte mais là où ils vont aujourd'hui
faire des discussions sur une réforme
générale sociale qui soi-disant va être
peut-être un marqueur aussi mais c'est
maintenant qu'ils veulent en discuter
alors que s'ils en avaient discuté avant
sur la problématique des carrières
longue des conditions de travail etc
peut-être que la loi aurait été discutée
différemment au niveau de la retraite
pas la faire passer dans la sécurité
sociale et je pense que ça a été fait
complètement à l'envers et on n'aurait
pas eu ces réactions là et puis et puis
toutes ces discussions toutes ces
réunions des premiers quinquennat avec
le premier réforme des retraites c'est
vrai que on a quand même beaucoup
discuté aussi hein
c'est une histoire de méthode c'est
d'alternatives on aurait dû proposer un
plan B peut-être un peu de
capitalisation peut-être parce que là on
a resserré sur la défense de de du
système de répartie par répartition et
peut-être que c'était aussi
ce qu'on peut lire aussi notamment dans
le rapport du corps c'est que on impose
ce qu'on oui il y a 350 pages
mais en même temps il y a plusieurs
hypothèses c'est ça c'est le problème
des hypothèses c'est de dire que il y a
le problème des retraites mais il y a un
problème économique de dette et que
cette réforme en bloquant à 64 ans au
lieu de dire c'est 43 ans de parce que
ça aurait pu être une piste ça aurait
été plus efficace c'est de dire dont on
met 64 ans parce que des gens qui ont
plus de 43 ans de cotisations on met
quand même 64 ans pour pouvoir justement
engranger de de des Finances qui vont
pas servir à la retraite forcément qui
vont aussi servir à la dette d'être
forte à la suite du covid donc il y a
quelque chose on aurait dû parler
financier c'est aussi pour ça que ça
énerve un peu certaines personnes en
disant c'est pas c'est pas que pour la
retraite quoi donc je pense qu'il y a un
problème de méthodes et de brutalité qui
est pas comprise non plus par la
population brutalité du 47 ans que vous
avez expliqué du 49-3 enfin bon donc ça
ça passe pas après c'est la Constitution
je me souviens qu'on dise que la 49-3
c'est pas c'est c'est un signe du
dictatorial que l'on a entendu enfin
c'est quand même la Constitution ça a
été utilisé plus de 100 fois depuis le
début de la cinquième république 47 ans
aussi mais ça veut dire que si on
utilise ce véhicule sur l'autorise
critiquer les critique pas est-ce que
c'est le bon véhicule pour pouvoir faire
passer une retraite aussi importante de
passer par le 47 ans 49 3 et la sécurité
sociale
je pense qu'on arrivera de toute façon à
une fin on va chercher une issue et une
fin il a l'issue l'issue politique elle
ne pourra pas se faire sans l'économie
il y a nécessairement obligation de
considérer aussi l'économie parce que
moi ce qui me m'interpelle parce qu'il
m'inquiète dans cette histoire c'est que
il y a d'énormes coups d'opportunités on
peut résumer ça comme ça tout ce qui est
mis dans l'énergie pour faire en énergie
pour faire grève pour parler
vulgairement c'est ce qui n'est pas mis
pour travailler même si ça peut choquer
mais tous ces éléments toutes ces
dépenses qui ne vont pas produire à
terme forcément un résultat parce que il
faut quand même voir qu'il y a autant de
personnes 60% 70% régulièrement qui sont
convaincus qui sont contre la réforme et
qui sont convaincus qu'elles passeraient
depuis le début il y avait autant de
population exactement
qu'on fait ça à fond perdu donc il
arrivera un moment où il faudrait
peut-être dire et bien arrêtons arrêtons
de ces pertes et puis considérant que il
va arriver un temps ou si on n'arrête
pas c'est l'économie qui ce qui aurait
du mal à repartir la résilience sera
mise en cause et
de savoir si
ces grèves plus les questions dont on
parlait tout à l'heure Florence
c'est-à-dire les problèmes de l'énergie
du coup de l'énergie et cetera va ne
vont pas affecter la question de
l'emploi ça c'est essentielles on est à
7% pour l'instant ça va mais l'objectif
c'était le plein emploi c'est 5% on y
sera pas et dans les dans les calculs du
cœur ou du corps on voit bien que ces
hypothèses qui ont été qui ont été
reprises qui peuvent altérer fortement
les résultats
pour préciser la si la loi est validée
par le conseil c'est pas une fin en soi
parce qu'il y a aussi après derrière
tout le travail de les décrets
d'application donc là aussi ça va être
ça va générer un certain nombre de de
négociation et de travail les décrets
alors c'est le Conseil d'État là après
alors non c'est le gouvernement c'est le
gouvernement c'est le premier
qui prend les décrets non mais qui qui
le jugent pardon c'est le Conseil d'État
qui sera le qui sera le juge ressorts
des décrets ils sont contexte
un tout petit mot pour rester sur le
problème de financement des retraites
c'est que il mécontentement des de la
population c'est de voir aussi toutes
les très grandes entreprises qui ont
dégagé des bénéfices énormes et
gigantesques et je pense qu'il y a une
partie de la population qui se dit mais
pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait financer les
retraites en allongeant de deux ans
le travail et pourquoi est-ce qu'on
n'est pas allé chercher
sur ces super profits pourquoi est-ce
qu'on les a pas taxés alors c'est la
politique du gouvernement c'est de dire
on n'est pas plus d'impôts mais sur
c'est super profit ils disent mais
pourquoi ça ça aurait pas pu aussi venir
pour pouvoir financer la retraite sur le
déficit qui qui va arriver d'ici 2030
mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on a pris ce
choix là alors que nous on est au SMIC
on a des salaires peu importe et on est
quand même impacté par toutes ces
problèmes d'énergie etc ce les Espagnols
ils ont monté les cotisations
qui auraient pas généré tous bazar on
change de sujet peut-être des parce que
c'est une question importante sur le
fond mais c'est une question importante
pour la vie de démocratique c'est la
convention citoyenne sur le sur la fin
de vie qui était une convention plutôt
calme plutôt sérieuse on en parle
[Musique]
une convention sage de 17h c'est vrai
parce qu'il y avait la Convention sur le
climat avec peut-être l'erreur de dire
qu'on prônerait d'emblée toutes les
toutes les mesures qui seraient voulu
par cette convention et après le
gouvernement et le président de la
République sont rendus compte que
c'était impossible là dès le départ il a
été dit que tout ce qui serait proposé
par la Convention ne serait pas
forcément l'objet de la loi donc ça
c'est intéressant sur le plan de
démocratique c'est vrai qu'on a un
problème de démocratie en France on sait
pas très bien comment comment faire la
démocratie représentative semble plus
être
tout à fait aussi efficace qu'on le
voudrait c'est vrai que c'est une
procédure intéressante cette conventions
citoyenne
intéressante oui en théorie c'est
intéressant je suis à titre personnel
assez sceptique sur le recours de plus
en plus systématique aux citoyens comme
étant un pseudo expert en politique
publique ça mais ça c'est mon ça c'est
mon c'est mon avis personnel mais
effectivement il faut trouver de
nouvelles formes de citoyenneté de
démocratie pour
des trottinette la votation etc
effectivement c'est une c'est une
avancée on va dire c'est une avancée
démocratique ce qui permet à la fois de
d'articuler de concilier des intérêts
qu'on appelle profane des personnes qui
ne connaissent pas forcément le domaine
et des scientifiques il faut voir que
dans la composition de cette convention
là je l'ai noté alors il y a des
représentants du CESU des représentants
du milieu de la recherche universitaire
des représentants du conseil consultatif
national d'éthique du concentre national
des soins palliatifs et puis deux
citoyens qui ont participé à la
Convention citoyenne sur le climat plus
plus les 100
sondage qui appelle les gens voilà
est-ce que vous voulez faire partie ou
pas ce qui est effectivement intéressant
c'est que sur un sujet qui est quand
même extrêmement complexe à la fois sur
le plan juridique évidemment mais sur le
plan philosophique morale éthique
religieux aussi il faut pas les oublier
et bien on s'aperçoit que les
propositions de cette convention sont
assez je vais pas dire consensuel mais
elles sont quand même assez assez
équilibré assez équilibré il y a pas de
il y a pas eu de véritables affrontement
de véritables en tout cas en apparence
d'opposition
dans ce qu'il dit c'est c'est il faut
améliorer les soins palliatifs donc ça
c'est très consensuel effectivement mais
après 15% ils sont mais le fait mais il
n'y a ça me semble petit il n'y a pas
une une majorité écrasante sur il faut
légaliser
35%, je crois c'est un peu une majorité
dedans là parmi les votes mais c'est pas
une majorité absolue en tout cas et ce
qui est intéressant
oui c'est une procédure démocratique
c'est peut-être aussi un moyen de se
débarrasser d'un sujet très compliqué
enfin c'est c'est vrai que c'est un
sujet sur lequel il est très compliqué
de légiférer pour des raisons simples
c'est que c'est d'abord
la phrase de de Régis Debré qui disait
la fin de vie c'est toujours la fin
d'une vie
[Musique]
pour dire que cette cette convention
permet alors d'abord de d'informer les
182 personnes parce qu'elles ont eu des
sémitaires des séminaires des formations
par des sachets et des experts qui
étaient extrêmement enrichissant et
peut-être qu'il y en a certains qui ont
évolué dans un sens ou dans l'autre sur
sur le sujet et
après que va faire le gouvernement de
ses décisions alors sur l'amélioration
de la fin de vie sur les soins
palliatifs c'est réclamé par quand même
beaucoup beaucoup de familles parce
qu'il y a un déficit en France de
d'endroit où on peut avoir des soins
palliatifs alors que c'est quand même un
lieu de fin de vie qui est quand c'est
bien fait
un problème de de l'approche de la mort
parce qu'on dit la fin de vie mais c'est
aussi l'approche de la mort donc
c'est ça c'est extrêmement important
pour le malade que pour la famille parce
qu'elles sont aussi dans le dans les
soins palliatifs accompagnés entourés et
là ce qui est aussi intéressant c'est
qu'il prévoit de pouvoir mettre en place
des soins palliatifs à domicile ce qui
n'est pas facile je pense ce qui est pas
simple parce qu'il faut être entouré
c'est peut-être plus simple dans un lieu
soit hospitalier soit il parlait des
EHPAD mais les EHPAD quand on voit des
fois certains EHPAD déjà
pas du tout équipé pour les soins
palliatifs déjà qui sont moyennement
équipés pour les soins quotidiens des
personnes âgées donc c'est vrai que
c'est un vrai problème après il y a les
deux grandes questions
qui sont qui sont le suicide assisté et
où l'euthanasie est où je dis parce que
ça peut être les deux la grande
différence suicide assister c'est là
c'est le le personne elle-même qui
souhaite mourir qui se voilà qui qui
aider par le corps médical l'euthanasie
c'est le corps médical qui décide de
mettre fin à la Convention ils ont bien
dit que l'euthanasie était très
exceptionnel c'est exceptionnel voilà
c'est exceptionnel mais
évidemment ça pose des problèmes
éthiques alors après je vous dis parler
de la religion c'est vrai après on est
dans un état laïque personne même s'il y
a une loi personne n'est obligé de la
suivre absolument mais je n'oublie pas
que s'il doit y avoir ça passerait
probablement soit par le Parlement
alors après il peut y avoir des
considérations religieuses par pour le
permis des parlementaires ou alors
éventuellement par référendum on sait
jamais peut-être que sur un sujet de ce
type ça pourrait je dis bien en théorie
ça pourrait mais là aussi ça des
questions religieuses pourraient aussi
en train de mieux alors c'est vrai que
beaucoup de lois notre récentes
notamment on contourner à la lèvre je
veux dire donc on a contourné des des
prescriptions religieuses mais sur une
question de ce type je
il ne faut pas mes estimer le
poids de la tradition de la valeur aussi
très étonnant c'est que les sodas les
vins sondages qui se baladaient qu'il y
avait plus de 90% des Français qui
étaient favorables à l'euthanasie
c'était très ça veut rien dire quoi 90%.
et d'ailleurs c'est intéressant que la
convention n'est pas suivi un peu cette
aire du temps
trop simplificateur autrement dit quoi
alors j'ai lu un article d'un
néerlandais il y a 20 ans
qui a évolué là-dedans et maintenant qui
fait marche arrière qui disait en gros
à l'époque il disait on était pour la
pour l'aide à la fin de vie parce que
les gens avaient peur de la mort et et
aujourd'hui ce qui craint c'est que au
fond les personnes âgées ou diminuées et
peur de la vie
de vivre quoi d'être un poids d'être
mais au-delà de ça ce qu'il disait c'est
qu'il y a un vrai danger de de
d'ouverture de de cette loi vers
d'autres vers d'autres spectre notamment
sur les mineurs donc ce qui explique par
la convention mais il dit attention
parce qu'au départ
une loi qui était équivalente à ce qui
peut ou pas sortir de la convention mais
que petit à petit ça s'est ouvert c'est
intégré les mineurs c'est intégré des
personnes âgées qui pas forcément
auraient pu dans le cadre de la loi
d'origine en bénéficier et que ça
devenait extrêmement dangereux sur de
l'euthanasie entre guillemets de
personnes qui sont pas forcément prêtes
à mourir et que c'est très dangereux et
disait attention en France de pas avoir
des dérives comme nous on peut avoir des
dérives au Pays-Bas je pense qu'on
pourra jamais vraiment cerner les motifs
parce que les motivations sont comme on
disait individuelles et donc on peut pas
prévoir un système qui répondent à des
motivations qui peuvent changer qui sont
individuelles et généralement l'état
quand il décide parce que là c'est bien
état qui va essayer de décider à ma
place il y a quand même trois types de
concernement il y a le concernement
individuel collectif et étatique donc le
collectif peut parfois être
en questionnement avec l'individuel on
demande la vaccination individuelle
parce que c'est un bien collectif une
protection collective donc là
l'individuel est de collectif peuvent se
comprendre l'état lui est celui qui va
contraindre qui va contraindre d'aller
vaccination donc le concernement
étatique vient de ce que l'État a
compris et il va imposer aux individus
mais là sur cette question enfin moi je
suis très très mal à l'aise sur cette
question parce que je crains à la fois
les dérives ça c'est évident je ne sais
pas jusqu'où on peut considérer que la
demande d'un malade est entendable ou
qu'il est vraiment en pleine possession
de toute sa capacité à décider
en même temps on entend aussi pour être
un peu dans un registre un peu moins un
peu moins triste c'est ce sont aussi ces
expériences médicales on nous dit qu'on
pourrait vivre jusqu'à 100 ans et voir
plus et qu'on recherche comment comment
éviter la dégénérescence de tous les à
la fois des éléments je dirais des
organes et l'apparence bon tout cela
un animal fantastique qui
vit un ravi deux ans le rap du vit 30
ans on a essayé de l'injecter tous les
cancers du monde ils attrape pas et donc
c'est un objet de curiosité formidable
pour les scientifiques et qui pensent
que oui on peut arriver d'ici quelques
années à vivre sans 30 ans sans aucun
problème comme on peut comme si on avait
50 ans
d'un milliardaire américain absolument
et qui a essayé et qui est-ce qui a 50
ans
donc on peut suivre exactement ce
traitement
des enfants ça parce qu'ils peuvent pas
la succession ils vont l'attendre
très très longtemps
les fondations après donc le problème de
la aussi de la dérive c'est sur les
personnes qui sont psychiatriquement
atteintes et qui disent que
psychiquement elles peuvent pas vivre
oui mais c'est ça
bien sûr
c'est ça qui peut être très compliqué
sur l'évolution de
c'est vrai que le
Suisse enfin juridiquement d'ailleurs
c'est très intéressant parce que le
suicide n'est pas condamné pourquoi
l'assistant se suicide le serait-elle
parce qu'on apporte l'arme oui c'est
vrai mais bon
a priori il n'y a pas de complicité s'il
y a pas d'actes
quelqu'un qui suicide j'allais dire
normalement et par elle-même c'est elle
qui se fournit absolument fenêtre qui
prend les comprimés voilà c'est pas
quelqu'un
non mais bon
pour connaître qu'on a le droit de
choisir sa mort
d'embarquer les médecins là-dedans parce
que certains médecins
il est là pour aider à vivre il est pas
là
la mort donc on voit bien que on voit
bien que c'est un débat c'est pour ça
que je disais que fou cette convention
citoyenne c'est peut-être aussi un moyen
de se débarrasser d'une question
extrêmement sur laquelle il est
extrêmement difficile de légiférer toute
façon Parlement si jamais mais
voilà ça donne peut-être une une
légitimation plus forte mais ne
serait-ce qu'on pourrait philosopher
là-dessus mais est-ce que on a un droit
à mourir oui je sais pas je ne sais pas
le droit de mourir oui enfin c'est un
droit de l'homme mais c'est enfin un
droit de décider
le droit de décider de sa propre mort
est un droit de l'homme mais c'est pas
un droit à mourir
c'est que qu'on accompagne sur la
dignité un cheminement vers la mort dans
la dignité les droits à mourir je sais
pas si on peut dire ça
c'est compliqué
il y a d'ailleurs cette association qui
s'appelle mourir dans la dynique
formidable mais le terme le terme mourir
dans la dignité est tout à fait
contestable parce que ça veut dire que
les autres sont indignes c'est plutôt
c'est plutôt la liberté de mourir que la
dignité de mourir qu'il faudrait à mon
avis enfin mettre en avant bon c'est un
autre débat mais non
ça veut dire quoi
certains dans bah oui il y a certaines
conditions
on a on a un petit moment un tout petit
moment pour parler de d'être trottinette
c'est intéressant il va falloir
descendre des trottinettes
[Musique]
de thé
un naine de thé c'est pas facile
d'écrire trottinette
non justement on parlait de de nouvelles
voies de démocratie voilà c'est une
étude et on pourrait penser justement
que la démocratie directe est plus
facile au plan local qu'au plan national
or quand on voit le peu de
pourcentage de gens qui ont été votés
pour cette votation vous a appelé
ça pose comme un problème
alors ça pose ça pose effectivement
problème alors juste pour pour rappeler
les conditions du vote c'est que les
mérite Paris avait conclu des contrats
de concession avec les opérateurs de
trottinette et ses contrats arrivent à
échéance donc il faut savoir si on va
les renouveler ou facile à mairie il va
les renouveler ou pas et donc elle a
décidé de d'organiser une consultation
pas une appeler sa votation c'est une
consultation des citoyens pour savoir
donc quel sens aller voilà tout
simplement donc ça c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose c'est que la
consultation qui a qui a eu lieu c'est
pas un référendum c'est juste une
demande d'avis qui a été organisée non
pas en vertu de la Constitution non pas
en vertu du Code général des
collectivités territoriales mais en
vertu d'un autre code le code des
relations entre le public et
l'administration qui permet aux
collectivités de choisir une troisième
voie de consultation sur la manière dont
ils peuvent dont elles peuvent pardon
organiser leur service public bon peu
importe en tout état de cause c'est une
un sondage c'est tout simplement un
sondage
et surtout vu le faible taux de
participation je pense que la mairie de
Paris ne se va pas s'estimer lié par le
par le sauf que le vote va dans ce sens
qu'elle souhaitait ça tombe bien
effectivement mais voilà c'est une
simple demande d'avis et c'est vrai que
sur la démocratie participative comme on
dit leur terme que je n'aime pas mais
bon personne voilà sur ce sur ce thème
là moi ce qui me ce qui me donne de
l'urticaire je vais le dire très très
clairement c'est que beaucoup de gens
ont estimé j'ai vu ça passait sur les
réseaux sociaux on nous a volé le vote
etc c'est scandaleux je le faible
mauvais alors c'est vrai que
l'organisation est peut-être pas
terrible
il faut attendre 40 minutes
moi je suis pas principe contre
l'interdiction des
je pense que je pense que le problème
n'était pas l'interdiction ou pas
l'interdiction c'était la réglementation
c'est une réglementation qui quand vous
voyez trois personnes sur une
trottinette sans casque sans rien il
faut les arrêter tout de suite je pense
que plus l'organisation que l'existence
même des des trottines qui vous a un
problème mais bon en fait moi ce qui me
puis après je vais arrêter de parler ce
qui me choque c'est le conclu donc
beaucoup de personnes contestent cette
cette votation et les résultats mais ce
qui contestent ne sont pas les votés
surtout ceux qui étaient contre qui sont
allés voter c'est la symétrie du blâme
alors
se mobiliser
coûte donc celui qui est vraiment très
très décidée vous avez raison sur la
réglementation parce que là on voit
l'image là il y a des incivilités ou
c'est n'importe quoi et même pour les
personnes handicapées
et puis il y a quand même beaucoup de
gens qui conduisent des trottinettes
n'importe comment n'importe comment
n'importe comment le problème des
conducteur c'est n'importe quoi mais oui
mais mais encore une fois puisque
démocratie participative démocratie
directe c'est vrai qu'on pourrait penser
que
je sais pas organiser une référendum on
l'a vu enfin on va le voir sur le plan
national c'est compliqué sur le sur le
plan local ça me semble beaucoup plus
simple et mais que les gens participent
que les gens participent mais oui on
n'est pas habitués et si on nous dit je
participe on n'a pas non plus un
résultat cohérent donc c'est compliqué
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup à tous les
trois encore bravo Raphaël pour votre
exploits merci beaucoup Florence
[Musique]